you
you
you
please join me today in giving a GSB
welcome to Don Valentine
I didn't realize there were this many
people had no place to go at noon I want
to thank all the women in the room for
Zappos this is the only company that
we've ever done where the product was
priced inversely proportional to the
amount of material that made the shoe
so if you ever hear any lady or
interested in or involved with talk
about shoe prices the number of pairs of
shoes they have it is amazing and you
can wonder after that introduction what
we were doing investing in primarily
ladies shoes fortunately I say totally
facetiously
fortunately Amazon bought Zappos for
from us about four months ago and I say
they bought it because we were not
selling it and if you can believe it we
had a big argument at Sequoia whether we
want to sell it for a billion three once
we establish which currency we were
talking about the argument was short
you might ask or wonder who these people
are and you might recognize some of them
but there's one interesting distinction
on this slide as far as I can remember
very few of them went to the Stanford
Business School there are two very
distinguished guys in this slide Jerry
Yang is at the top of the slide
and the reason I point him out first is
that he did a building with the proceeds
of his yahoo success and the man right
below him Jenson Wang also did a
building which is opening today so today
is a big day to celebrate the results of
some of these characters that you see
before you they were selected randomly
as were the companies it's always nice
when you can make the slide that shows
the success and apply your selective
memory to those other companies that
didn't make this light but let me begin
by talking about a question that's often
asked I do a lot of the interviewing and
recruiting of people joining Sequoia and
one of the subjects I asked them about
is who's got the water I asked them
about is why do you want to join Sequoia
assuming you think we're successful why
do you think we're successful what have
you learned and it turns out that many
are most of the people in the venture
business historically would answer that
question by telling you they
finance the best and brightest the
greatest managers and all that stuff we
do not which maybe is why you don't
recognize a lot of the people in the
picture we have always focus on the
market the size of the market the
dynamics of the market the nature of the
competition because our objective always
was to build big companies if you don't
attack a big market it's highly unlikely
you're ever going to build a big company
so we don't spend a lot of time
wondering about where people went to
school how smart they are and all the
rest of that we're interested in their
idea about the market they're after the
magnitude of the problem they're solving
and what can happen if in fact the
combination of Sequoia and the
individuals are correct so if we just
think of the picture where Jerry is
profiled at the top what were we
thinking when we financed Yahoo or maybe
more accurately the picture in the in
the upper left hand side for you the two
founders of Apple what did they have in
mind they had in mind the idea of you
all having your own computer the
opportunity to have your own computer
then was a deck 100 computer a mini
computer that cost two hundred and fifty
thousand dollars now I know the tuition
is high here but I don't think a lot of
you come here with deck 100s simply
because there was no way to
visualize a world in which the computer
was ever going to be cost produced from
the price that Dec had a debt to the
computer prices that you face now and
using Apple as an example one of the sub
questions that I was encouraged to talk
about is how do you go about picking
choosing we don't choose people we
choose markets and once we choose a
market there's a primary product and we
rarely ever invest in an area where
there's only one product so if you take
Apple none of you are old enough to
remember that the original system
governing memory was an audio tape
player now you have to really have a
great sense of humor using an audio tape
player as a primary memory they were
highly unreliable and they took forever
to download the information so we knew
if you think of the Apple computer as a
system we knew we had to finance one or
more memory companies disk drive
companies we had to have initially
floppy disks what needed financing disk
drives that made the memory information
portable and fortunately for us IBM had
always had a facility in San Jose where
they located their R&D for memories so
this was a very fluid community we
helped ourselves to some of the people
from IBM
financed several companies in the disk
drive business one of which achieve
revenues of a billion dollars without
the memory system the PC is nothing so
if you keep digging away at the system
what else do you invest in well Xerox
was very generous being an East Coast
company and I have a slide that I'll
savor a little bit that features my
vision of Xerox Xerox had a place called
Xerox PARC and when the Apple people
went to Xerox PARC
that they found a few things that they
needed they found a mouse so we financed
all of these things that we found at
Xerox PARC
they had the best GUI on the west coast
Apple has always been famous for having
a superior graphic interface thanks to
the generosity of Park and their people
who were very gracious at sharing so
this is how we chose to invest on a
system application level we looked at
the system the Apple computer and in the
final analysis made over 15 investments
in that category and one of the
investments we made was an application
investment the guy with the sweater on
top started Electronic Arts we started
the company in our office and at a point
in time when they had more people in our
office than Sequoia people we asked them
to leave
but that's how electronics art was
created and I'll give you another
illustration of the six degrees of
separation concept being applicable but
we have always tried to a Gregorian a
platform and Apple is the example that
is probably the most visually prominent
right now Steve was not always the best
marketing guy in the world just recently
but marketing is one of those things
that people underestimate there was a
company called Sony that had 90 percent
market share in mobile music how many of
you had a Walkman how many of you don't
have a Walkman
you have one of Apple's products which
if you think about it is a Walkman on
steroids fidelity is better the number
of musical choices are better so a lot
of products if you miss a generation of
phenomenal knockoffs of huge market
shares held by companies like Sony and I
can't resist wrong direction the
dinosaurs are very alert this morning my
view of the board of a big company Xerox
was in Rochester the open Xerox PARC and
they conducted a technological picnic
for a number of years where the
companies in Silicon Valley ate lavishly
at the picnic given by Xerox Sony was
very gracious at donating a product and
as far as I know they haven't struck
back with any attempt to deal with Apple
that took their entire market why does
that happen
well a lot of the boards are developed
and built around the end of all thinkers
and they don't get any better
Xerox one of my favorite tragedies was a
spectacular company in Rochester New
York had all the patents had market
share huge profits cash flow that was a
dream and they were persuaded by some
people in Wall Street to move from
Rochester to southern Connecticut
and to change the nature of the company
and become a service company so they
became an insurance company they became
a Wall Street brokerage kind of company
and they left all of the right people in
Rochester where all the patents were and
everything and when that move was made
to Connecticut I have to believe that
somewhere in Tokyo Rico
Samsung and everybody else who were
planning on taking their market share
away applauded the fact that Xerox was
abandoning their strengths and going in
a direction that made no sense you have
to select a board like that to do that
so we've established the fact that in
our case the market is everything and to
us we have gone into business with some
people who had absolutely no business
credentials and we organized the
companies in ways so that the people who
are going to run them who are often
younger than you are could run them
based on the limited experience they had
so we taught them outsourcing we tried
to explain to them that making
everything in-house might have worked
for Sloane and the Ford family but
certainly not recently
we tried to teach them that you only had
to do a couple of things well in our
companies you had to be very good at
technology and engineering and that
normally took us about six people to
start the company the second functional
skill we were always interested in
establishing was marketing so that we
could tell what the dynamics of the
market work with our checkbook and
Sequeira we were not interested in
creating markets it's too expensive we
were interested in exploiting markets
early so that when we were with the
right set of people wait a minute we
didn't want that these are the the right
people technologists people who had a
dream of some way to solve a problem
most of them were not interested in
becoming wealthy that was an accident
they were interested in solving
technology problems and creating new
products and many of them have done it
brilliantly and that is the sort of
cornerstone history from our perspective
about how and why we start companies how
we choose less the people and more the
market because people from our point of
view are readily available and this has
been a hotbed of training grounds so
every time a company succeeds here every
time 1969 came around and Intel started
and a couple years later they had all of
their momentum started you had a whole
bunch of people management in training
so we have been very generous at
circulating people throughout the
community there are a couple of
organizations that have been
repositories of Technology SR I is is
one of the historic ones I've already
mentioned Xerox there's one that you
wouldn't ever have heard of called a
wagon wheel and what was the fourth one
IBM these companies were incredibly
critical to the formation of most of the
great companies in Silicon Valley
because they made a component part of a
system which in our case if you were
investing in systems in applications the
solve big problems now why did Cisco
come out of the blocks screaming their
IT department was where the product was
developed interestingly and the problem
was pcs had now populated the remote
offices in big companies and the
information packets coming from the east
to the west that Lightspeed had a hard
time finding the right mainframe so you
had a condition called broadcast storms
there were collisions of these packets
all over the place
Cisco's solution was to design a product
called a router which merely identified
something coming in Lightspeed and
directing it to the right end location
initially they did this from a private
home in Atherton
until the Atherton police found out
and they sold them to all of the other
IT departments in all of the other
universities with their first approach
to customers but here is an illustration
of a product that was derivative of a
number of our other experiences that led
us to hear about the packet problem the
broadcast storm problem so finding
people who knew something about that was
a matter of search and we have always
had a search function looking for the
people that we want to populate our
companies with unlike other people in
the venture business we don't wait for
you to knock on our door we knock on
your door we know generally speaking in
a lot of respects which kinds of
companies which kinds of products and
therefore which kinds of people so the
people to us become very important for
their fundamental technical skills when
applied to a particular problem that
we're interested in solving a different
approach than many people in the venture
business have followed I don't suggest
that it's the only approach and I
certainly don't want to leave you with
the impression that it always worked we
have some companies that are beyond the
concept of hideous and failures hard to
believe I understand but
so one of the things I meant to mention
earlier is that when we talk about
questions I have a rule about questions
I don't answer any questions that are
more than 20 words I'm not interested in
your making a speech
but if you have a question figure out
how to express it
in less than 20 words now I'll tell you
about a real experience because one of
the things that's true in my world the
art of storytelling is incredibly
important and many and maybe even most
of the entrepreneurs who come to talk to
us can tell the story so one day there
were three entrepreneurs and by accident
there were three people from Sequoia and
this guy started at the Adam and was
ranting about how they were going to
change the world with this product after
20 minutes I just decided that we're not
going anywhere
his other two founders were frustrated
so I asked him for one of his calling
cards he gave it to me and I said we're
going to take a timeout and during this
five-minute timeout you're going to
write your business plan on the back of
your business card and then we'll come
back and have you start over and those
are the only words you get to explain
the ones that are on the back of your
business card now it was more humorous
than not this man turns out could write
in microcode
I thought I had done something clever to
help him so he must have had 500 words
on the back of his calling card his
calling card was the same size as
everybody else's
learning to tell a story is critically
important because that's how the money
works the money flows as a function of
the stories and what are the critical
things I would encourage you to learn
that's way more important important in
my world than anything else is how to
ask a question because you want to have
the person comfortably
telling you what he thinks is important
so that you get it now for a long time
we don't understand the product or the
market while we're listening so we have
learned to string questions in a way
that provides the entrepreneur with a
way to explain what he wants to do how
long it's going to take who the
competition is how much money he needs
without feeling threatening for many of
the investments we've made we didn't
understand the answers but we constantly
work on developing the questions and
when we have had a company that's failed
we always have post-mortems at Sequoia
because we're trying to understand what
we missed what question didn't we ask
what answer did we not understand
because we're dealing with amateurs
storytellers and it's important that
they comfortably can tell you what's
relevant
and despite our audience which is made
up of almost exclusively technology
people and people who have been founders
of companies questions think about
questions which is why I have this 20
word maximum I normally have 15 but I'm
giving you a little latitude here one of
the questions that's often asked us is
where the people who populate Sequoia
come from and the answer is pretty
broadly geographically here
we're less interested in their education
then we are interested in what they did
in their prior companies so the man who
joined us this week I brought his resume
just to highlight for you his name is
Alfred Lin Alfred is not in the picture
at accident we financed Alfred's first
company which was eventually acquired by
Microsoft in I believe 1996 small
company Internet company before we
really developed the momentum IBM came
and bought it we were not trying to sell
it
alfred was the chief financial officer
Alfred second company which we financed
in 2004 with Zappos he was the chairman
he was the chief operating officer and
one of the people who admitted to
knowing absolutely nothing about women
shoes so we started a company which we
sold to Amazon their revenues when we
sold the company or about seven hundred
and fifty million dollars a year all the
shoes was sold over the net there were
no bricks and mortar there were two
enormous inventory locations one in Las
Vegas and one in the name of the city
I've forgotten where Federal Express has
all airplanes someplace in Tennessee
where is it why did we put the inventory
in those places because we committed
basically to 24-hour delivery and that's
where the planes were and Alfred had
figured out a few things about how to be
in the retail business it wasn't totally
a sexist company there were about 10 or
15% of the shoe solar for men how many
of you here have ordered shoes on Yahoo
excuse me
did you know yahoo soldiers just testing
alfred as is true with a number of
people over time is one of those people
who will work within sequoia as well as
start companies outside Sequoia will use
him as we have used people like him in a
multi tasking way wherever he feels as a
company he's specially interested in and
some people really like to do that and
they're good good at it and alpha
happens to be one of those so right now
Alfred is at Sequoia but we're all
looking forward to what comes next
what company is Alfred going to take us
to which business will he take us to
because the first two businesses were
entirely different from one another so
he's a clever versatile person who knows
what he doesn't know think about that
because the entrepreneurs that we
finance oftentimes are clueless about
what they don't know and what we try to
do is supplement through our rolodex and
through the people at Sequoia we try to
supplement what they don't know so we
try to make the job of starting the
company and the management of the
company as easy as possible we don't do
functions in-house that we can outsource
so the last person we hire and the
management team is the financial officer
why do we need them we don't have any
money
the founders are spending it as fast as
they can they're developing the product
which always is to be generous a little
late it always cost more money than the
founders said but we knew that we would
finance a lot of companies and the
results are all same so we try to make
the management job extremely easy don't
manage any function that you can hire
someone else so we have people who act
as CFOs for our little companies and
they may do two or three of these
companies at a time and there's only one
metric that matters in finance in our
world and it's cash flow so we hire
people that are wizards at cash flow we
don't have balance sheets we love
recessions best time to invest in our
experience for a lot of reasons but
recessions don't hurt nobody is buying
we're in product development usually
banks don't lend they don't lend to us
ever so it's not unusual so we look
forward to recessions and the
environment veteran recessions now I
didn't tell you early on because I don't
believe in giving you all of the
surprises in the front I had a special
advantage going into the venture
business and I think no one else of my
relative contemporaries had that
advantage and I know this is one that
might take an esperan in a slug of water
to deal with but I knew the future
and if you don't think knowing the
future is a great advantage it is a
phenomenal advantage I spent 10 or 12
years in the semiconductor business all
of the products that are here operate on
microprocessors
I came from the world where they
invented the microprocessor the guy I
work for a Bob Noyce name is on the
patent for the microprocessor and we
spent huge amounts of time trying to
figure out which applications we should
attack in which order so knowing the
future made it easy for us to very early
on invest in a company like Atari we
invest in Atari in the early 70s
microprocessors were in production
Intel's started in 69 they went into the
game business coin-operated games as
well as home games all microprocessor
driven Apple almost every significant
company we were involved with we
understood what it is they were going to
use where to get it how much to pay for
it and it was relatively easy to aim the
entrepreneurs at things that were
Silicon intensive because that was the
technological future people have asked
why haven't we invested outside of
Northern California and the answer I
always gave was if we were in a plane
flying east we were leaving more
opportunities on the ground in Mountain
View
then we would ever find in any Eastern
City so I would ask you to think about
any place in North America where venture
capital has worked any place in Western
Europe with 350 or 400 million people
where it's worked it basically has
worked in Northern California and my
definition of work is look at the
monuments some your biggest biotech
companies were started here and it
wasn't called Silicon Valley for nothing
so this was a an opinion that we held
strongly that we didn't have to go
anywhere else and I used to sort of
tease our limited partners about why we
didn't finance companies in choose a
state and I told him that I thought the
reason would stretch their credibility
but that the Catholic Church was wrong
the world is flat and once you go past
Denver you go off the edge into a
technological oblivion
who would volunteer the name of a city
or an area where venture capital works
my definition success has to breed big
monuments it's not Boston and you'd look
at Boston II and look at the Bay Area
and think God their schools or at least
as good as ours why doesn't it work we
have had visitors from around the world
the latest one was unbelievable the
State Department brought the Prime
Minister of Armenia and out of curiosity
we agreed to see them after scurrying
around and finding a map and finding
Armenia
it's unbelievably far east of the
Mississippi and the State Department
brought these people in and we had
guards I mean the Armenian guys had ten
or twelve of their own guys the state
department brought in seven or eight
others and I said you know guys we don't
have a conference room with that many
chairs some of you can't come
you have to stay outside so we talked
with interpreters and they always have a
gift so they gave me this gift one of
those coffee table books and I looked at
it quickly and the prime minister said
not to worry
it's in two languages the second
language was Russian so I have this book
in case any of you are doing research on
Armenia and you have the book so I'm
going to segue in a slightly different
direction and I'm going to test you by
asking one of you to ask a question 20
words or less or I'll kill you there's a
brave man here in the front we have a
microphone coming your way
what did you learn from your worst
investment that
there anybody here from Armenia I mean I
need an interpreter I didn't get the
question what did I learn from our worst
investment we have invested in a lot of
companies and this is not a statistical
business so we've had a lot of failures
failure is somewhat of a definition
dependent issue but we learned that we
have never made a bad investment where
the technology didn't work it didn't
work when they said it was going to work
they spent more money doing it
but what didn't work was the dynamics of
the market we have we have developed
some pretty spectacular things for which
there were no buyers
now what their buyers eventually yeah
but the critical thing is getting a
product developed where the timing of
the products availability and the market
demand or simultaneous otherwise you're
spending lots of money on developing a
market which you did not intend to spend
money on and invariably we tend to shut
those investments down now to some of
you that may sound harsh and to some of
the founders of those companies it
certainly did sound harsh when we said
we're not going to finance you anymore
because no one wants the product and we
just don't see any prospects
which gets me to answer the question
where do we get the money from we
decided in the beginning that we wanted
to have all tax-exempt sources so we
could avoid difficulties with liquidity
and selling things in order to make a
distribution to pay someone's taxes so
our limited partners over roughly 40
years have been taxed exempt we have as
examples most of your universities
wherever you went because we have
probably 50 different universities we
have a large number of us foundations we
have a reasonable number of
international primarily Western European
limited partners so the money comes to
us from sources like that which we
aggregate in partnerships it takes us in
a 500 million dollar partnership it
takes us roughly three or three and a
half years to invest that money and
investing that money includes the amount
we reserve for future rounds of
financing it was we never financed
anybody totally on day one we financed
them there are milestones depending on
how well they do meeting the milestones
we then refinance them and it's all done
very critically and if in fact the
return expectation that we started with
is no longer reality we oftentimes shut
the company down now keep in mind we're
financing companies that have ten people
many of these financings are done in our
office so they have a lot of free rent
free lunches free a lot of things but if
they don't get it they don't get any
more money and yes it's it's necessary
to make these kinds of decisions so I
think the announcement was that we
financed 500 companies it wouldn't
surprise me if we hadn't shut down a
hundred of that 500 over the years
because the expectations for success
would no longer realistic
are you just airing out your armpit or
you haven't asked a question I think you
need a microphone or at least stand up
so everybody can hear you actually I'll
pass it back to him let me complete my
question I'll hand it to excuse me sorry
sorry but sky curtain or zoom is all
about aggression don't worry he's
aggressive the question I had not part
of it on the famous or infamous rest in
peace presentation you published if you
published it today what would change in
why
I'm not sure many are most of you heard
the question early on in this particular
recession a lot of our presidents were
asking what to do about spending what to
do about hiring so we decided to have a
meeting a very private meeting in a
local place that we never have meetings
in to talk about this openly and
positively we wrote a paper and you have
to understand what slides like mine
there's a lot of people at Sequoia with
a a ghoulish sense of humor so the front
page had a tombstone that said r.i.p
those of you who are not currently
fluent in Latin this was a secret
only people invited there were
management in our companies no publicity
two days later I saw the paper on CNBC
I'm ordering if we were trying to get a
paper on CNBC we would never succeed the
answer to the question what impact well
it had a lot of impact on our presidents
and management because we were
interactively discussing what the
alternative ways to operate the
different companies were in this kind of
a recessionary environment these are
companies that don't have very much in
the way of cash and not a lot in the way
of borrowing ability well this paper
apparently people that I know on the
East Coast called me and they said you
scared everybody to death and I said I
don't know how or why we were just
trying to scare 70 people to death and
you were not on the list amazing the
Internet has a lot of great features not
all of which were positive and there was
an example of what we were doing very
privately being publicized worldwide
because we had limited partners in
Europe contact us and wanted to have a
conversation about what we were thinking
it wasn't fun
what's that new law unintended
consequences one of the most significant
unintended consequences we never have
meetings like that with all of 70
presidents where the message is caution
keeping the powder dry being thoughtful
on expansionary kind of spending ideas
and we got more publicity than we ever
imagined so I want her to tell another
story because there must be people in
the audience harboring an opinion or
resentment because there's only one
woman in the slide which for us is
pretty good
this woman was one of about six founders
of Cisco and these are the people in
Atherton shipping homemade routers to
their opposite numbers in the IT
departments around the country and this
woman was one of the core members of
management she invented a concept called
customer advocacy in her opinion the
customers were not well cared for as a
generalization and she was going to
ensure that Cisco was not guilty of
paying attention to the customers pretty
heady stuff in the startup well this
lady also happened to be smart but tough
beyond all comparison and forgiveness
was not in her vocabulary and when
somebody in the management of this
embryonic company didn't do it the way
she wanted it she shredded them publicly
and the president whom I had hired to
run Cisco who was the chief executive
and it was his right to make the
decision he wanted to terminate her and
I said you know it's your call but I
would encourage you to find a way to use
this talent because it's an unusual
talent and I think its core to what will
differentiate his company so he agreed
they had a conversation she took an oath
of behavior
I wasn't there for that and the next
thing I knew about a month later there
was seven vice presidents of Cisco in my
office
and their position was very simple
either the seven of us stay and Sandy
leaves or sandy stays in the seven of us
leave what's your preference so I
listened for a while being one of the
world's greatest listeners I mean if
you're going to laugh laugh but don't
murmur
so I called the president I said John
you I I have a war ready to be declared
in my office here what do you want to do
and he said I can't make it work
Sandy's got to go so sandy was separated
from the company the company was
monumentally successful it went public
that is her partner in a number of
respects both of them left a then public
company with a hundred and seventy
million dollars each and she hasn't
spoken to me in 15 years I might be
lucky there's no telling what you would
say
so decisions are sometimes made but you
don't like to see made when a creative
force in a company that's doing a lot
more good than evil has to go because
otherwise you have to build a whole new
management team including the president
the footnote on the president John
morgridge is that he ran the company
from basically nothing to revenues of a
billion five he left because that's all
he wanted to do he did an extra five
hundred million as a favor but he wanted
to leave the company at a billion
dollars in revenue and and do something
different so John was the most
like me president I have a heart now
what does that mean he was the only
president I ever heard was cheaper than
me he would go to huge lengths to stage
talks for the management of the company
about spending this was a company
growing extremely rapidly had gross
margins of 68 percent was monumentally
cashflow positive they currently
generate in free cash on a 40 billion
dollar sales base they generate six
billion dollars a year in excess cash so
john's lesson the DNA he created has
done the company a lot of good where is
this clock you mentioned to me
ah we're over time they said if I didn't
provide you enough opportunity to ask
questions I wouldn't get lunch owing to
the fact that I was late
going through the labyrinthian
directions I had
can we can we do any questions where is
the microphone uh he has he has custody
responsibility which which markets
excite you today and which market
currently in vogue in the valley gives
you the greatest pause or concern
answering the question backward the
question is about the markets that I
like in the markets that I don't like it
probably started three or four years ago
there was a huge you and cry about Nano
everybody wanted to do Nano so we were
not thrilled about nano we listened to a
lot of people a lot of presentations and
turns out in our opinion and bear in
mind we have a lot of semiconductor
background and the semiconductor
business is a processed business it's
chemistry
and nano is a process business
there was no applications that you could
easily point your finger to and say we
can do a product in all of those areas
and sell it to a lot of different people
one of the companies was going to attack
the catalytic converter in your car
which uses a precious metal and they
were going to substitute a less precious
metal and sell that to the car companies
that was still in business and we took a
pass on nano it may have been a mistake
it may be that all the great successes
in nano are in front of us but so far I
don't see any notches in anybody's rifle
as a result of investing successfully in
nano now the positive side of the
question is what do we like and we
continue to like the exploitation of
mobile steve has demonstrated a whole
bunch of consumer oriented applications
there are lots of other things to be
done in the mobile space in our opinion
but we don't focus on one category to
the exclusion of other categories we
have teams of people that specialize in
different areas of developing a
knowledge base and market sizing
information about where we should be
spending time and I have established for
you that we tend to invest in an
application system approach which may be
the reason why it didn't work in nano
but it's the reason perhaps why it does
work in mobile
thank you